Hmm.
Oh,
hi bill.
My name is [inaudible].
My question is about giving some chance
to the chance.
Um,
the power ability of winning a lottery
is very,
very small.
Nevertheless,
it's playing lottery rational.
Thanks.
The lottery Uri,
Uri,
I've got to tell you when I first I,
it doesn't sound like you're in the u s
I grew up in the u s and I lived in
Seattle,
Washington for a while now Washington in
the United States as a western state.
It has old traditions and the big thing
is it's not as populated as other states
in the u s and there was a lottery.
There is a lottery and they used to
think it was kind of charming and people
want to play the lottery.
Okay.
Yeah,
that'll be fun for them.
The chances of winning are very,
very small,
extraordinarily small,
almost everyone who ever plays ever
loses.
And he used to think it was benign or
not any big deal.
But I have changed my mind about that
over the last 30 years.
The lottery is mostly a tax on people
who don't know math.
And the reason they don't know math is
because people like me have failed to
enlighten people on what it really
means.
When it's one and 230 million,
it means you will lose.
That's what it means.
If you have a one in 230 million chance
of winning,
it means you will lose.
And uh,
when I was doing standup comedy,
I used to have a joke,
a joke about having a revolver,
a gun,
where the bullets are arranged in a
circle.
I don't know your ancestor Uri,
but you might be from uh,
one of the eastern bloc countries in
Europe.
And we have an expression in the United
States,
Russian roulette,
where there's one bullet in the gun and
you spin it and then you hold it to your
head and see whether or not you'll die.
And that's a one in six chance
traditionally.
But in the lottery it's one and 230
million or 450 million.
So imagine a gun with 449 million,
999,000,
999 bullets in it and one empty chamber.
You would not hold that to your head for
$2 ever.
And so I feel bad that uh,
the people who play the lottery are
generally people with lower education
and lower incomes.
This,
these are statistical facts.
So we are accidentally taxing people who
can least afford it.
And it's frustrating for me as a science
educator.
So,
uh,
my advice to you is don't play the
lottery.
Use your dollars for something else.
And if you do play the lottery a,
I understand you get some pleasure out
of it,
but keep in mind you almost always lose
and wait,
there's more to it that it preys on this
other aspect of nature where we embrace
the successes and forget about the
losses.
This is how psychics make their living
palm readers and so on that you remember
when they accidentally said the right
thing and you forget when they said
dozens of wrong things.
So people,
when they bet a dollar and they win a $5
lottery ticket,
$5 reward,
they almost always reinvest that $5 or
the $4 to buy more lottery tickets.
It's really,
it seems like a cool idea.
And now in the United States,
there's huge state incomes based on
lotteries,
but in the biggest sense,
it is a tax on the people who can least
afford it.
It's frustrating.
I'm frustrated.
Thank you for asking that question.
Eri.
Hmm.